en el video anterior vimos el mecanismo
para la formación de iminas en el que
empezamos con un aldeido o cetona y
agregamos una amina y un catalizador
ácido si y es igual a un hidrógeno o un
grupo alquilo esto es una imina pero si
y es igual a un Oh entonces es sería una
oxima lo escribiré
oxima esta palabra parece una
combinación entre oxígeno e imina ahora
si el grupo y es igual a nh2 o nhr b
prima esto es una
hidrazona
hidrazona el mecanismo es igual ya sea
que hayamos formado una imina oxima o
hidrazona y queremos regresar a nuestro
aldeido o setona original solo
necesitamos incrementar la concentración
de agua un exceso de agua y catálisis
ácida empujará el equilibrio hacia la
izquierda regresando a nuestra amina y
nuestro aldeido ocona veamos un ejemplo
aquí tenemos una imina y añadimos un
exceso de agua en un ambiente ácido si
observamos esta molécula podemos ver que
tenemos al nitrógeno Unido con un doble
enlace al carbono que a su vez está
unido a un grupo r y un grupo r este
sería el grupo r prima Así que
regresaríamos para formar una acetona
Entonces nos quedaría ciclohexanona al
hidrolizar nuestra imina uno de nuestros
productos es la ciclohexanona y el otro
producto corresponde a esta parte nos
queda una amina si pensamos en el
mecanismo perdimos dos protones Entonces
tenemos una amina primaria ahí está esta
reacción también puede funcionar para
oximas e hidrazonas echemos un vistazo
aquí tenemos esta reacción empezaremos
con cicloexano y esta vez usaremos
hidroxilamina y un catalizador ácido
este grupo Oh es nuestro grupo y vamos a
identificarlo el grupo Oh es nuestra y
Así que pondremos un Oh Unido al
nitrógeno que estará Unido con un doble
enlace al carbono dibujemos los
productos empecemos con nuestro
anillo Y en este carbono tenemos un
doble enlace con el nitrógeno que ahora
en lugar de estar unido a un hidrógeno o
un grupo alquilo se une a un grupo Oh y
tenemos este par de electrones libres
Esta es nuestra oxima las oximas son más
estables que las iminas por el hecho de
que aquí tenemos un oxígeno con algunos
electrones libres que se pueden mover
hacia acá empujando estos electrones
hacia el carbono así que podemos dibujar
una estructura de resonancia nuevamente
dibujemos el
anillo y este carbono está unido a
nuestro
nitrógeno ahora tenemos un doble enlace
entre el nitrógeno y este oxígeno que
solo tiene un par de electrones libres y
también tenemos un par de electrones
libres en este carbono lo que le da una
carga formal negativa resaltemos algunos
electrones estos electrones en el
oxígeno se movieron hacia acá y estos
electrones se movieron al carbono
formando un carbanion en nuestra
estructura de resonancia Entonces al
mover algunos electrones ayudamos a que
este carbono pueda
estabilizarse sabemos que aquí tiene una
carga parcial positiva y por eso la
densidad electrónica ayuda a que se
estabilice Esta es una forma de ver por
qué una oxima es más estable que una
imina ahora analicemos esta acetona
hemos estado usando cetonas simétricas
en donde los grupos r son iguales en los
dos lados pero ahora tenemos una acetona
asimétrica y agregaremos
hidroxilamina obtendremos una oxima pero
tenemos dos posibles productos como
estamos empezando con una acetona
asimétrica podemos mostrar en nuestro
nitrógeno un par de electrones libres de
un lado y el Oh del otro Este es un
posible producto y el isómero de esto
nos
quedaría El par de electrones libres
ahora está del lado izquierdo y el Oh
del lado derecho Estos son nuestros
isómeros podemos ver que el
Oh se encuentra en lados contrarios al
doble enlace Así que podemos obtener
isómeros como productos si empezamos con
una acetona
asimétrica lo mismo ocurre con las
iminas pero las oximas son más estables
que las iminas Y es más fácil aislar
isómeros de una oxima muy bien hagamos
otra reacción en lugar de tener un grupo
Oh ahora tenemos
nh2 como grupo y regresemos a la
reacción
general cuando y es igual a
nh2 obtendremos una hidrazona como
producto será el mismo mecanismo la
reacción de una hidracina Esta es una
hidracina y al reaccionar con
ciclohexanona nos da un
anillo y aquí tenemos un doble enlace y
nuestro
nitrógeno esta vez nuestro grupo y es
nh2 esta es nuestra hidrazona y aquí
tenemos un par de electrones libres las
hidrazonas son más estables que las
iminas porque este nitrógeno tiene un
par de electrones libres y podemos hacer
lo mismo que hicimos antes Esta es
nuestra
hidrazona muy bien
hagamos otro sobre formación de
hidrazonas este se ve más complicado
pero observen que aquí tenemos nuestro
nh2 y después tenemos todo esto podemos
pensar en esta parte reaccionando con
nuestro carbono en el carbonilo Y
nuevamente es una reacción por catálisis
ácida así formaremos una hidrazona todo
esto puede ser una rb prima dibujemos el
producto tenemos nuestro anillo y luego
tenemos un doble enlace con el
nitrógeno Ahí está ahora simplemente
dibujamos el resto de la molécula no
importa en qué lado ya que es simétrica
la pondré del lado
izquierdo tenemos otro nitrógeno unido a
un hidrógeno
y luego tenemos nuestro anillo
aromático y los grupos Nitro saliendo
del
anillo Esta es una reacción muy famosa a
este compuesto se le llama 24 dnp
24 dnp o también 24 Din nitrofenil
hidracina y es muy famosa porque se
utiliza como un test diagnóstico para
aldeidos o cetonas ya que al reaccionar
con aldeidos o cetonas da como resultado
un precipitado naranja o rojo y ese
sólido tiene un buen punto de fusión Así
pueden caracterizar al deidos y cetonas
sin tener que utilizar aparatos más
complejos que determinen las estructuras
ahora existen muchas otras cosas pero es
muy interesante echar un vistazo a todo
esto